officials say the alleged gunman in
Buffalo's mass shooting chose his Target
because of the high percentage of black
people in that particular area which
raises a question how did that
neighborhood become so segregated in the
first place a University of Michigan
analysis found that the Buffalo Niagara
Falls metro area overall is the sixth
most segregated in the whole U.S and
another study by the University of
Buffalo concluded last year that the
economic conditions for black people in
that City had not improved in three
decades we spoke to Professor Henry
Lewis Taylor who worked on that study
and who told us why Buffalo's east side
looks the way it does today
the process of segregation is driven by
the way in which we build cities within
the urban areas ever since the rise of
home ownership in the United States
there have been a sorting and sifting
process to separate higher income whites
from lower income blacks back in 1940
Buffalo was one of the most integrated
cities in the United States but as home
ownership increased and as we saw this
land valuation system occurred blacks
were concentrated in places on the east
side where the most undesirable
residential lands in the city existed
and is there a connection between that
history and what we saw unfold this past
weekend I think it's a big connection it
if you drive around this neighborhood
and community and you see folks living
in the dilapidated and run down houses
these streets and sidewalks that are
literally non-existent the unkept vacant
Lots
black people fight against this so
because the people in the neighborhood
like this fight against the condition of
the neighborhood it makes them a Target
it makes them a Target
I take it you were not surprised or
already knew that this was the only full
service grocery in this area there are
over a hundred thousand black people in
Buffalo and the fact that there's only
one major Supermarket servicing them is
a disgrace
but that was years of struggle and and
battle and fighting it just didn't
happen and so it it represents a symbol
of Hope and possibility it represents
what we can accomplish When we struggle
just to get one food store so that's
what this food shop one of the few
places where we can get nutritionist
food to eat and you attack it
you attack it
you're the anguish in his voice
Professor Taylor is incredibly
knowledgeable uh and passionate speaker
his point is that when you look at the
built environment around you remember
it's it's not an accident that it looks
the way it does and it's not a choice
either it's deliberate yeah just like
this attack was deliberate well done
Tony